>> Good evening everyone.
See, I would like to talk
on Salaam Mumbai Foundation
and its program.
Basically, my name
is Devak Patel,
and I'm part of
Salaam Bombay Foundation.
Salaam Mumbai Foundation is one
of the branch of
Salaam Bombay Foundation.
Salaam Bombay
Foundation basically
work on tobacco control.
So, Salaam Mumbai Foundation
which works in
rural areas and
Salaam Bombay Foundation
which works in urban areas.
So, basically,
Salaam Mumbai Foundation
are raised in 2007 and
our prime motto objective is
that making all schools
are tobacco-free,
and that's why we will engage
and train our trainers.
See basically at Maharashtra,
we are working in all entire
districts of Maharashtra.
There are 34 districts in
Maharashtra, and
out of Marahashtra,
we have replicated
these program in
other state of India as
Rajasthan, Karnataka.
We are Karnataka in Dharwad
and Havere districts,
and Gujarat West Bengal.
So, we are in
seven states of India,
and basically in order to reach
large numbers of children,
and teachers direct, it's
very difficult to go
and conduct negotiations
with the children, teachers.
So, that's they will
develop different strategy,
like we train the trainers.
We train the trainers and once
they get trained by our trainers,
trained by Salaam
Mumbai foundation,
then our trainers go
to their districts and
train other teachers.
So, that is the strategy
we have develop.
Then of course, we engage with
ministry and the stakeholders
because at large level,
we required permission from
the government and
all these thing.
So, that's why once they get
motivated from
Salaam Mumbai Foundation,
we get permission from
Education Department,
and then we started implementing
program in the [inaudible] India.
So basically, these
are the objectives in
order to achieve
these objectives,
we have replicated program
in different parts of India.
So, as I said before that,
it's very difficult to go and
meet each and every child,
each and every trainers,
teachers that's why we
develop different strategy.
We train the NGOs,
we train our stakeholders,
like master trainer.
So initially, we have started
programming in
Chandrapur districts
in the eastern part
of Maharashtra,
it's very remote areas
and tribal areas.
Initially, we started
programming 10 villages,
where we realize that
tobacco consumption rate is
very high amongst the
male and female both,
and adult and youth also.
Initially, when we did
a survey in the 10 villages,
we found that almost 45
villagers using tobacco.
I mean, all the tobacco
types are productive.
It include superior also.
So, what we feel is that
[inaudible] are equally
harmful to the tobacco,
because in Maharashtra
sweet tobacco
is banned by the
government not by NGOs.
It is band by government,
but it's not properly implemented
by Enforcement Agency,
that is different part.
But it's banned by the
government in Maharashtra.
Then, gradually we feel
that it's a burning issue
not only in small districts,
burning issue in all over
the Maharashtra
because as of now,
if the GATS data
says that almost in
Maharashtra 26 percent adult
use tobacco in Maharashtra.
If you think about
the India level,
29 percent rate, tobacco
consumption rates in India.
So, that's why we
started implementing
program Maharashtra gradually,
expanded program in Maharashtra.
As of now, we have covered
all the districts of Maharashtra.
We directly go each and
in every districts,
we train the teachers.
We have develop lot of
digitized material
and hard copies,
and all these thing,
and based on that,
the teachers and NGOs
started implementing
this program as their own,
in the schools and community.
So, in 2014 in Ralgad district,
there is a Mhasala block,
and there are around 136.
Schools are there right from
first two to As standards.
So, all these schools have
become now tobacco free.
We have kind of evidence
that all these schools,
now if you go and meet
the teachers you will
find that no one teachers
are consuming tobacco.
I mean, how can we say
that these schools
are tobacco free?
There are criteria
developed by CBC board,
and based on that criteria,
we declare that these schools
now has become
a tobacco free schools.
These are the criteria.
Follow that criteria
each and every level.
In 2015, we conducted
a pledge activity in
Yavatmal across districts.
Then that pledge registering
Limca book of records,
and we also got
some Vysaanmukti Award
from Maharashtra
government because of
no greater work on tobacco
control at India level.
Now, what we feel that there
is some kind of limitations.
As a NGO, we're talking
with teachers like,
talk on effects of tobacco,
tobacco free schools etc.
So, our real issue it was not to
become a mandatory
to the teachers.
Like they were saying
it's the NGOs agenda.
It's not our agenda.
How can you say that
you talk on tobacco,
effects of tobacco and
tobacco free schools.
But now we made
timed up adequacy with
the government, and law.
In 2015, government
got convinced,
and they integrated like
anti-tobacco messages
in school curriculum,
in Maharashtra.
I'm talking about Maharashtra,
and in there stand also
they're integrity
anti-tobacco message they see.
Government in Maharashtra,
government has also developed
kind of like
government's software,
where we integrated that
all 11 criteria in their system.
So, that now it's become a
mandatory to all the teachers,
like they have to enter
all the tobacco-free school
data in that system.
So in 2017, we succeeded on that,
and also this is all
are done of Salaam
Mumbai Foundation.
We initially started
program 2007.
Now, we are in say
one state of, as of now,
we train around 80,000
teachers at seven states,
and now around 4,000
have become tobacco free in
the state of Maharashtra.
So, that is the milestone of
Salaam Mumbai Foundation.
Next. So, we have developed
like digitized material.
So as of now,
we have different kind of
films and all these thing.
We have developed
Tobacco Free School app.
Once you type on
Google Play store,
the app will come on practice,
and then teachers and NGOs can
easily enter the data in
that Tobacco Free School app.
So, we get all the evidence.
Before two months back,
we declared an
underbar districts in
Maharashtra that these districts
are tobacco free.
This is why we declared
their district because we
have kind of evidence.
No one can challenge that.
How can you declare
these district?
The important thing
is that as an NGO,
we don't have that kind of power.
That we can declare the district
is tobacco free No.
So, we convince magistrate
that see we have like
one 1,400 evidence received
from the teachers,
and based on that, you can
declare that this is our received
and all schools have become a
tobacco free, and then we start
Mallinath Kalshetti is
the district magistrate
of Nandurbar district.
He declared that our districts,
all schools are
tobacco-free districts.
Now, this year,
[inaudible] dream of
Salaam Mumbai
Foundation that we are
expecting that in Maharashtra,
there around one lakh
nine thousand schools
in Maharashtra,
and we're expecting that
all schools should
be tobacco-free.
But how can we make that
schools tobacco-free
unless we get data
from the teachers?
We'll talk on the barriers of
the Tobacco Free School app.
Now, we have developed Salaam
Mumbai Foundation websites
where we have uploaded
all the films, stories,
booklets, and lot of
best stories, success stories,
government GRs,
notification, FDI
notification, et cetera.
So, we've also Salaam
Mumbai Foundation
Facebook page developed,
Learning Management System
like any one.
Now, this Learning Management
System is a system,
is a kind of website,
if you want to learn
something about
Tobacco Control Program.
Once you complete that course,
you will get certificate online.
So, that system will come in
practice after
maybe one or two months.
So, it will help to
strengthen program at
village and school level.
So, that is overall about
digitized material, and really,
I can say that
the digitized material help
us to strengthen program at
school and community level.
>> I think the challenge
that these guys are facing,
and I'm interjecting here,
is that they have
enough digital information
available to them,
but it's stand alone
and it's static.
It does not have
any intelligence in it.
They've not been able to do
any predictive analysis,
nor have they been able to
do some prescriptive
analysis which could
be further used as
influencing mechanisms.
So, the opportunity lies
here is that there is a mine
of digital data that's already in
place across all Maharashtra,
and that's a significant
amount of data set.
If that can be put
through an engine which
can provide some intelligence
around it, it will, a,
give us better decision
making, second,
lot of their process is
today manual in nature,
in terms of data collection and
in terms of other aspects.
So, how can that be digitized?
So, that's the
opportunity statement out
here that we have from the team.
So, open to any
questions you have.
>> Yeah, please.
>> So, this is
a very big success story.
Congratulations. My question is,
what kind of data do you
have on the basis of
which we can make some kind
of predictive analytics?
For example, data on
individual students
or class level
so that we can make
some predictions about,
this student is not
going to become
tobacco-free or this student
will become tobacco-free,
or something on the basis
of which we can say,
this student needs
more intervention
and this student does
not need intervention,
so that we can do
something of that type with
respect to prescription.
So, I wanted to get some
idea of what you're
thinking about.
>> So, we have collected
school-wise data.
We don't have individual
data at present,
but it's a really good idea.
But now, this is our learning.
Now, just we've replicated
program in Uttar Pradesh.
District name is Pratapgarh.
So, there, we have done
baseline survey with
the children and teachers.
But in Maharashtra, we don't have
that kind of
baseline survey data.
>> So, the basic concept is,
if the children are kept far from
tobacco and other harmful things
up to the age of 18,
then it's very likely
he will stay away for
the rest of the life.
It's very difficult.
The Maharashtra state
has one [inaudible] nine
thousand schools itself,
and it's very difficult to
reach each individual student.
As an NGO, we don't have
that much capacity.
So, the design was to
work with the schools.
We have law, we have guidelines
from the CBSE board.
So, if we could make
schools tobacco-free,
then the children
don't have access
or they're not exposed to
this kind of substance.
It's likely to impact
their life positively.
So, idea was that.
So, we have data.
Like we have schools,
there is U-DISE number.
Each school is identified with
a unique identity number.
So, with that number,
schools can login. Yeah, sorry.
>> [inaudible] So, from
the school level data,
would you be interested in being
able to make
some prediction about,
this school is going to do well
or this school is not
going to do well,
because based on that,
then we can intervene
on one school
versus another school?
Is that the kind of problem
that you're interested in?
>> No, I think we are open.
What you suggested, we
can also explore that.
The major concern
was the schools.
They're not entering
the data, basically.
So, the reach is
the concern also.
Though we did
district-level training,
we did all block-level training,
but the teachers are
not that convinced.
Maybe some IC material
can be added to the app.
So, the reach is the concern
and, yeah, individuals.
>> Specifically, which kind
of problems we are facing as
regarding Tobacco Free
School app, see, teachers,
their mindset is that if you
are doing such kind of work,
government gives us online data,
and all these things.
It's extra work for them.
Second thing is
that low connectivity
in remote areas,
electricity problem.
So, such kind of
problems also we face.
So, that's why we don't get
much more data from the teachers.
>> So, thank you, guys. Can
we take the question during
the breakout sessions so
the team is available? Yeah?
>> One point which came
up in conversation
with their program head was
that they have this
trainer-trainer program.
So, there's a lot of disparity
in the quality of content which
gets layered from one trainer to
another because of
transmission loss.
So, they wanted to
make the program
more uniform and apply
the best practices from
the most successful trainer
to the other trainers.
So, maybe [inaudible] can you
track that what this trainer
does better so that we can
replicate that trainer, XYZ.
>> All right. Thanks,
Richa, for it.
So, now, we'll get
the [inaudible] team up
and talk to you guys
about their program.
>> Thank you.